- [Other Tyler] Intro?
- No.
Nope.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 230
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm ready. Dunk.
- [Dunk] First
question from Seth.
- Yep.
- What's up GaryVee?
My name is Seth Silvers.
I live in Denver,
huge Broncos fan
which means we have
one thing in common:
we hate the Patriots
and I hate Bill Belichick.
So in 1999 when Bill Belichick
was the head coach of
the New York Jets for--
- Two days.
- a very brief time he famously
said for various reasons I'm
choosing to resign as the
head coach of the New York Jets.
Were you happy when that
happened you hate him yet or
were you sad and the real
question is how many Super Bowls
do you think the
Jets would've one if--
- Yeah, I have no
interest in this question.
Let's move on.
- Thanks, look
forward to your answer.
- [Dunk] Next
question is from Alex.
- Uh-huh.
- Self-awareness is
very important--
- This guy's wearing
a Chiefs fuckin' hat.
- but self-discipline
can be even as important.
How do you continue to be
self disciplined each day
especially how did
you stay self disciplined
in the early stages
of your entrepreneurship journey
when the results
might not be there?
Chiefs 20, Jets 17.
Thanks.
- There's just no options Alex.
I stayed self disciplined
because I wanted to win.
People talk about wanting to win
but they don't actually want to
win and they're not willing
sacrifice to win and so I did it
'cause there was no, there
was never a moment in my time
whether it's hardwiring or
understanding of the situation.
There was never situation
where I thought that not being
disciplined or wavering was in
my best interest and so I think
when you're
fundamentally patient, as I am,
it makes everything quite easy.
Everybody's just antsy.
Antsy for shit to happen
so soon so it came very easy.
- [Dunk] Next
question is from Daniel.
- Hi Gary, my
name's Daniel Knowlton.
DRock or whoever is editing
this please hook me up with
my Twitter handle,
I appreciate that.
My question to you Gary is I've
just headhunted for position at
Facebook but I'm currently
running a small but growing
digital marketing agency in the
UK called KPS Digital Marketing
do I stop what I'm doing with my
agency and get some one else to
manage it and then go and
work at Facebook to get the
experience or do I ignore the
position at Facebook and carry
on hustling and doing what
I'm doing with my growing
digital marketing agency?
- [Gary] Daniel,
that's a personal question.
- I appreciate your answer.
- That's a personal question.
I can't answer that for you.
You need to know who you
are and what you're about.
My intuition is anybody that
even questions to leave their
own business to
go work at a company
should go work at that company.
- Yo, yo, what's up Gary?
Cory Gregory here just
pulled up to the gym,
wake your ass up 4 AM.
That's what you get when you
add right here Cory G Fitness on
Snapchat so here's my question.
I'm a serial
fitness entrepreneur.
I've been to businesses since
I was 20 years old so it's going
on 18 years now and I love it.
I'm known for on
Snapchat showing that daily
accountability, that wake
your ass up and it's nonstop.
I'm also known for content in my
space but I've never had like a
personal video guy that just
followed me around like DRock.
Tell me the difference it means
to your business to
have a guy like that.
I think I already know that the
answer but I'm thinking about
taking that next step in truly
having somebody capture what
it's taken me to do what
I've done in my career.
And I'll end with this we will
be friends so I'll see you soon.
Thanks.
- Corey, I think it comes
down to if you've got something
interesting to say or if the
content's interesting it has an
impact 'cause the
storytelling is good.
You know, as great as DRock is
at cinematography or editing or
Tyler or Dunk or Staphon or
fucking Steven Spielberg if the
subject matter isn't good,
it won't have upside.
Even us and I think nobody's
living a more fast-paced,
serendipitous for creative
content opportunity than I am
but look you know
it's a repetitive grind.
It's a challenge for these
guys to edit and make
a creative storytelling.
We're starting to interview
people within the organization
we have to mix it up because the
fact of the matter is a lot of
our lives take on a similar
cadence and so doing something
daily you know
people like Casey
and other people that
do it extremely well.
They look for the story,
they create the story,
I'm not doing that.
I'm documenting over creating
and so I want to show that grind
but dude there's only so many
times you can yell at us at 4 AM
and saying let's go.
You know, and so I think,
I think the impact on your
business and your career and
your brand will be that if
you've got chops, if you're
actually interesting enough,
if there's things going on
especially if they're not
fabricated or created for that
scenario and they're authentic
more people will be
interested in what you've got.
You create a wider net,
you get an opportunity
then to speak to them.
I mean some of the vlog, the
vlogging we're doing allows more
people to get into my ecosystem
and allows me to drill home
the four or five things that
I feel passionate about telling
the world because
I want them to win.
I think if, you know, if
you're there to sell products or
supplements or magazine covers
if I was here for selling you
know VaynerMedia or selling wine
or my book I think that they
would have less upside.
So I also think not only is the
storytelling matter but what is
the, what is the, thing you
are trying to accomplish really
matters in the
scenario vlogging.
I think Casey for example and
I have a lot of love for him
generally just is a filmmaker
and wants to tell stories.
That's why it does well.
Gonna be a lot of people that
vlog that aren't gonna do well
'cause they suck.
- [Dunk] Next
question from Joshua.
- What's up GaryVee?
Coach Kozak here and I just
like to get your thoughts on
friendships of a fellow hustler,
grinder out here in the shed
24/7 working.
- I like the shed.
- And I want to know at this
point in time in your life and
your career do
even make time--
- I want a shed.
- just to have those couple of
friends that are always nagging
me throughout the day.
Asking me if I've seen
this TV show or that TV show.
I'm mean at what point are just
being rude or do you have to
just tell these guys to,
"Hey I don't have
time for friends today."
- Look I love my friends and
I actually wish I spent more
time with my friends.
I mean the fact of the matter is
during the day outside of Jets
friends during Jets season
I don't communicate with anybody
about anything until that day's
wrapped up and I'll catch up.
You know, I think way too many
people are trying to be cool.
What the name?
Jonathan?
- [Dunk] Joshua.
- Joshua, I think too many
people are trying to be cool and
being like, "Yo, I don't got
time for fucking 'House of
Cards'," or like
following the life.
I don't think there's any,
ever a time to like
rag on your friends.
I think in my mind I rag on my
friends because but to actually
I want to be polite
and I want to give them love.
I think it's super important
to be empathetic to a million
different lifestyles and if
anything I'm trying to work hard
as a matter of fact I think
I emailed Tyler the other day
and I think I'm seeing a bunch
of my high school friends in the
city next Thursday
or this Thursday.
You know, I don't know.
I mean like they're your
friends for a reason, right?
I think a lot of people are
struggling with the definition
between friends
and acquaintances.
I think acquaintances that want
you to watch "Game of Thrones"
and play fucking Madden I think
if you really want something bad
are probably an interesting
thing to cut out or
navigate around.
I think friends you need to be
there for all the time and try
to fight for those relationships
because that brings as much
value as building the
biggest business in the world.
- [Dunk] Next
question is from Zach.
- Thank you, Dunk.
Who's strategy was it to start
with Belichick and
the Chiefs hat?
Did you guys think you were
gonna get some good razz?
- [Dunk] Razz to get it out.
- Okay, just curious.
- GaryVee, my
name is Zach Smith.
I'm currently a physical therapy
student at the
University of New Mexico.
I am a huge fan
of your work and
I am so grateful for all of the
value that you bring all of us
and I appreciate you
taking my question.
As a future business owner,
I'll be deploying a lot of your
strategies to
advertise for my business.
My question for you is which
platform do you spend most of
your time on these days?
Thanks for answering.
- Which platform?
I mean I think, what's his name?
- [Dunk] Zach.
- Zach, first of all,
thanks for the love.
Zach, I think
the plot, you know,
I think it's
running the gamut.
Instagram, Snapchat
I still continue use Twitter.
I don't think people understand
like Twitter is still the one
place to have unbelievable
engagement and I truly believe
so much of my world is
predicated on engagement.
That being said, Snapchat's
the place where when I actually
reply, I just get so many god
damn, you know, people go crazy.
It's funny, I love the way the
UI and UX of Twitter, I can just
get to so many more people than
all like the pressing waiting.
The speed in which Snapchat
engagement works doesn't allow
me to do as many as I'd like to
which is disappointing because
the upside of engaging on
somebody's
Snapchat is holy shit.
Whereas on Twitter
it's like thanks and
that's a very big
different reaction.
I would say
Twitter, Facebook,
Snapchat, Instagram.
That's where I'm spending most
my time and I think this is a
great opportunity for me to
answer a question so many have
been asking which is Instagram
Stories or Snapchat Stories?
The answer is both.
All four of those platforms have
enormous attention for me and so
I continue to focus on
them and engage
and create and pound and
work with my team on our
strategies and so all four
platforms are extremely
important to me as the pillar
and foundations and so there's
not one that is you
know is dominating.
I'm sure if I looked at my time
of usage, one is greater than
the other depending on how
I use them but in my mind from a
strategy standpoint all four are
extremely important and I think
for most of you all four
of those and including the
LinkedIn's of the world and
Periscope and the
Facebook Lives scenario.
I mean there's just so much
opportunity for us
to story tell and grind.
I just think people need to put
in the work and I think they all
bring different value for
different reasons and that's why
I use them.
Facebook has
ungodly reach potential.
Nothing is remotely close
to Facebook's capability to
replicate a
television like platform.
Instagram is just depth of
attention especially
with stories now.
It's done extremely well just a
month ago or eight weeks ago
I was talking about being
concerned of where
Instagram plays.
I think the Stories
feature was a monstrous move.
Snapchat for the 16 to 25 to
28-year-old demo is the game and
super important for so
many of us out there.
And Twitter is the only place
where you can listen at scale
and engage and
create that conversation.
I mean I don't know where
everybody was last night during
the debate but I have a funny
feeling it wasn't Instagram,
Facebook and Snapchat and so
that is the water cooler of our
society and there's a
lot of opportunity there.
May be for not as much talking
but is the one place I would
listen over any other platform.
That's it?
Question of the day what are
the social networks
that you're using most?
Sorry for the saltiness.
I'm surprised it carried over.
I was actually a fairly good
mood yesterday but looks like
some characters in my team
decided to put me in the salt so
went in the salt and I'm gonna
stay in the salt until
I get out of the salt.
Keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
That wasn't even right.
Finished.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.